listos para El despegue la NASA dijo que
la misión artemis 1 sin tripulación
tendrá otro intento de lanzamiento para
realizar su viaje alrededor de la luna
este sábado con pronósticos
meteorológicos favorables Y si todo sale
como se espera el cohete despegará del
centro espacial Kennedy en Cabo
Cañaveral Florida a las 14 y 17 hora
local la misión pretende lanzar el
cohete más potente del mundo y lleva
aproximadamente una década en desarrollo
artemis requiere de un vuelo de prueba
sin tripulación de seis semanas
alrededor de la luna
[Música]
Este es un vuelo de prueba y aunque me
siento muy bien con nuestros
procedimientos Cuando miras al equipo a
los ojos están listos no podemos
controlar el clima etcétera cualquier
día existe el riesgo de no poder
despegar Lo importante es que nuestro
equipo está listo
el lanzamiento genera emoción en el
público y tan solo algunos podrán estar
dentro del Auditorio Kennedy muchos
pretenden estar en cocoa Beach a unos
kilómetros del centro espacial para ver
el acontecimiento histórico la agencia
se vio obligada a posponer el
lanzamiento de artemis programado para
el pasado 29 de agosto tras registrar
problemas técnicos A última hora
nunca he visto nunca hemos visto ningún
lanzamiento Así que eso es muy
emocionante Aunque hayamos tenido que
regresar
artemis sucesora de las misiones lunares
Apolo de los años 60 y 70 están solo el
comienzo de un programa que tendrá como
objetivo el regreso de los seres humanos
a la luna y con el tiempo el aterrizaje
de misiones tripuladas A Marte